[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight spoiler video today I want to show
you another photo that was taken on the
Game of Thrones set and I think this one
is pretty interesting but I have to put
a disclaimer at the beginning of the
video and please listen very carefully
to what I say whenever I make a video
like this I always try to make it very
clear about how I personally feel about
these things but there is always that
one person out there who wants to twist
my words so let me start this off by
saying I do not know who is in the photo
nor do I know when it was taken there
are two different people who I think
this could be but your guess is as good
as mine
the photo was originally posted on Irish
Thrones Twitter page but shortly after
it was posted the person deleted it
maybe he deleted it because he knew it
was fake or maybe he deleted it because
he didn't want to reveal the source I
honestly don't know but I want to thank
my friend allow for bringing this to my
attention because he did take a screen
cat before it got deleted regardless who
is in the photo let's just take a look
and try to decide for ourselves as you
can see someone discreetly took a photo
of someone riding on a dragon in my
opinion that does not look like Daenerys
nor does it look like any other type of
clothes she would typically wear that
appears to be a man riding on a dragon
and as of right now the only man that is
riding a dragon is the knight king but
the interesting thing is the knight King
and Jon Snow
both were very similar clothes they both
wear high leather boots and they both
wear a thin layer of armor over their
clothes and it's very long almost like a
skirt that goes all the way down to
their boots it's pretty much the
traditional northern look which is what
this person is wearing on the dragon
even though this dragon rider is most
likely the night king there are a few
things that make me reconsider when you
look at the night Kings clothes you can
see that they usually have a blue tint
to their color even before they use
filters and post-production here is a
picture of the night King walking around
the set and you can see the green screen
in the back still and his clothes still
have a blue tint to them
but the person who is writing the dragon
does not have that same color to their
clothes now I know there is a bright
light shining down on the Dragon which
could change the color of things but it
still looks mostly brown to me also the
night King has a very unique texture to
his clothes and boots
there is ridges on his boots in this
photo and it's kind of layered like fish
scales which does look different than
the person who is on this dragon now
when you look at the pattern on John's
clothes it looks a lot more like the one
on the dragon it has the rectangular
shapes on it and the boots don't have
those funky looking ridges on them but
the biggest similarity is what is around
the person's waist look at the mane on
the dragon it appears as if he is
wearing a sword belt which we all know
the night king does not wear but John
does wear a sword belt John also carries
long claw on his left side so you
wouldn't see it in the photo of the
person on the dragon but like I said at
the beginning of the video I want to
keep this short because I don't want to
overanalyze this photo simply because I
don't know where it came from and I
don't know how old it actually is I just
thought it was interesting because the
clothes do look more similar to John's
then the night Kings in my opinion but
then again I know nothing what I do know
is we've never seen John on a dragon he
did pet dragon and Daenerys tried to
rescue him with her dragons but John
never actually set on one yet so there
is no reason for there to be any photos
out there of John sitting on this thing
unless he is writing one in season eight
there is also a chance that HBO
purposely put this on the internet for
people to talk about it but if they
wanted to spread misinformation then why
not just take a better photo
that clearly shows it's John instead of
just some person's leather armor and leg
if HBO already knows John will never
ride a dragon then they should just
release a picture of his whole body
showing his face with him sitting on the
green-screen mechanical dragon that
would really throw people off but since
it looks like someone tried to secretly
take this photo without people seeing
them do it it does add some intrigue to
the photo at least for me at the end of
the day it probably is of the night king
but I think there is enough differences
in his clothes and this person's clothes
to add some dowel
but let me know what you think about
this one who do you believe this person
is on the dragon put all your opinions
or questions down below in the comment
section I want to thank everyone for
stopping by to watch the quick video and
I also want to thank my patreon
supporters have a great day everyone
I'll see you soon bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]